Thank you,
Gretchen,
for making time for us.
Well,
thank you so much.
I wish I could take credit for the timing.
I mean I guess in a,
in a more subtle way,
I can in a,
in a way that coming forward 15 months ago has started this floodgate of other
women feeling the confidence and the bravery and the courage to do the same.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I don't know if we,
I imagine maybe,
maybe not,
we have a,
some Fox News viewers in the room or watching on live stream,
but for those who had didn't watch Fox,
um,
and this is really maybe your first time seeing Gretchen.
Can you tell everyone,
um,
you know what motivate you?
Write the book.
Obviously last year you were in the middle of a crazy media storm and now here
you are,
um,
you know the public face of this issue.
So after I jumped off the cliff by myself on July six,
2016 where my story broke and I filed a lawsuit against my former boss at the
company where I was working.
I mean,
I had no idea what would happen to me the next minute or the next day.
So it was really an out of body experience as it started to unfold and develop
really quickly with the results of my boss Pitney,
I'm being forced from the company and other women coming forward.
I could have never ever predicted that.
And also it started having it at the same time was that I started hearing from
thousands of women all across the country who started sharing their own personal
stories of pain and shame with me as well.
And I soon realized that this was a pervasive epidemic in our country,
that it wasn't just sexual harassment in the television industry or in
Hollywood.
This was from all walks of life,
from single moms who are working two jobs to make ends,
me as a waitress,
to members of our military,
to teachers,
to accountants to,
I mean it was every profession.
I grew up in the Midwest where my parents always encouraged me to write back to
people and correspond and write thank you notes.
So I started responding to all these women.
And what I found out was that they all felt so grateful that I was giving them a
voice because nobody had ever listened to them or to their story.
And from that,
I felt a sense of duty to put together a book,
not only to honor these voiceless women,
but also to give practical advice and move the ball forward on this issue.
And look where we are today.
You know,
in a short period of time,
as you just said,
this is the national dialogue right now.
Yeah.
Um,
so I know you can't discuss the specifics of your time at Fox,
but can you take us a little bit inside your state of mind?
Um,
the,
when you filed the lawsuit against Roger Ailes,
who we should remember was the most powerful man in media.
He had helped elect three presidents,
uh,
was a kingmaker in the Republican Party,
and presided over a ruthless.
A media company was known for attacking anyone inside and outside the company
who questioned Fox.
And here you were going to file a lawsuit naming him personally.
What was going through your mind?
Well,
courage building is not something that you do overnight.
I think it has a lot to do with how you're raised.
Uh,
fortunately I had parents who told me I could be anything I want it to be every
single day and that helped me to build courage from a young age.
Still when you decide to do something like this,
it's a process.
And the final nail in the coffin for me was when I realized that my job was
coming to an end after 25 years in the business and it was coming to an end.
That wasn't my choice to come to an end
that I decided if I don't step up and speak up about this issue and have
conviction on it,
then who else is going to do it.
And most important than me gave,
and you're a new father,
is you know,
I have a 12 year old son and a 14 year old daughter and I don't want them to
face the same indignities that I've gone through in my career.
And I was shocked that it was,
it was still existing in 2017 but I wanted to eradicate it for them or at least
do my part to do.
I think one of the things that was,
um,
unique to your situation is that,
you know,
a lot of women when they come forward are worried about their stories being
questioned or shamed or doubted.
And I think what was unique in your situation is that your colleagues,
uh,
that there was an orchestrated campaign to discredit your story.
What was that?
What did that feel like when people that you worked with were casting doubt on
your claims?
Well,
you find out who your friends are.
I mean,
not only you know,
coworkers,
but you find out in life.
Uh,
it was really fascinating.
You know,
some people who hadn't heard from in 30 years reached out to me.
And that meant a lot to me.
Some people who lived on my street never did.
Okay.
So it was interesting because as time went on,
people would approach me and say,
well,
I didn't want to bother you,
or I didn't know what to say.
Yeah.
You know,
it's kind of like when somebody dies,
um,
people feel tongue tied and it would have been just nice if they just would have
sent one little line in an email like thinking of you or whatever because trust
me,
when you do something like this,
you have a lot of incredibly dark days.
Yeah.
And
the only other thing I would add to either the trolls on social media or however
you want to describe those people that you just brought up,
um,
you can't waste too much time worrying about those who malign you.
Because you know,
really what I wanted to do with this mission was moved the ball forward and it
doesn't do any good to sit around and worry about people who said really bad
thing.
Just this week we had more revelations about Harvey Weinstein,
uh,
other prominent members in Hollywood and your former colleague,
bill O'Reilly,
sorted from the 30,000 foot view.
Where are we in this conversation that,
um,
your,
your book helping your story and now you're booked helping.
Yeah.
So I think it's absolutely horrifying that any company would protect a harasser
or a serial harasser for 30 plus years.
Yeah.
I mean,
listen,
you know,
harassers don't continue to be able to do that in the workplace unless they have
help.
So enablers,
lawyers,
assistance.
I mean,
these were all people who helped in the coverup and the shutting up of the
victims.
And we should all believe that that is absolutely outrageous.
So from 30,000 feet,
what I'm saying now is that women are finally feeling the courage and the
bravery to say enough already.
We're not going to take this anymore.
And looking at that,
me too.
Hashtag for me was just,
I mean,
that was so empowering just for me,
even though the stories were so awful.
Yeah.
It showed that every woman,
number one has a story,
unfortunately,
but also that we're,
we're not ashamed to speak up about it.
Yeah.
And we're shifting the shame from the woman where it never should have been to
the harasser where it belongs.
I mean,
I've been fascinated by the fact that we're still having this national
conversation.
Yeah.
And do you think,
um,
you know,
we were just talking before we sat down about Anita Hill and in a certain
respect,
you know,
sexual harassment in the workplace is not a new thing.
It's been something our s our culture has been grappling with for decades.
Um,
but sadly here we are in 2017 and you know,
we realize that someone like Harvey Weinstein,
you know,
who was exposed to be a serial Predator,
quote people knew and this was going on for years and it didn't stop.
I mean,
to me as a reporter,
you know who,
who covered ales,
his downfall and you know,
am always shocked that this behavior could have gone on with such high profile
people.
And no one said,
wait a minute,
this isn't right.
I know.
In fact,
in Weinstein's contract,
allegedly the board allowed him to go on harassing.
Yeah.
They knew it was happening and they just said,
well,
if another case comes up,
you'll have to pay us a fine.
Let me really,
the board of directors,
by the way,
none of them were women.
You allowed that kind of pervasive misogyny to continue
that is absolutely outrageous.
Yeah.
I mean that's where as is the focus in my reporting.
A lot of,
a lot of it has been on the,
the systems and the power that allowed this behavior to go on.
And,
and at Fox it was,
um,
a lot of it was a system that all set up to,
uh,
silence victims through legal settlements,
out of court settlements and Da's,
which we've talked about.
So to me that this is like with the Catholic Church,
um,
abuse scandal there,
this is the focus should be on the power,
not,
you know,
not the individuals.
It's the system that allowed,
uh,
this abuse to take place.
Um,
can you talk a little bit,
um,
uh,
Riley,
um,
to the degree that you can,
you know,
we learned according to the New York Times that Fox new signed him to a new
contract after knowing he made multiple out of court settlements,
does that indicate that the company was taking seriously protecting women or
were they willing to look the other way for ratings?
So if you read in the newspapers after my story,
there was going to be a new beginning.
Yeah,
and I mean I guess that would,
I'll let you make your own assumption about that since they reassigned him well
after my story had broken.
You know what I can say about that is that for any company to resign an
individual who had been dismissed for sexual harassment allegations and known
settlements already and then invite him to come back on the air just last month,
that is,
that is absolutely horrifying.
And to think that there was a cleanup on the way I,
I don't think I call that a cleanup
and the number itself,
I mean at $32 million private settlement,
I mean that,
I know Riley has been out there saying it's all bs and it's not true.
And I think the numbers speaks for itself.
I mean nobody spends that amount of money to settle a claim if there's not some
merit to it.
And I think
that's exactly what I tweeted at night.
You know,
I just said no,
nobody,
I don't care how much money you have.
Nobody pays $32 million for false allegations.
And it was,
I think the most retweeted tweet that I've ever sent.
Yeah.
Entire,
you know,
in my entire life.
I didn't even intend for that.
It was just my general reaction that,
you know,
and here's part of the problem,
and I know you know this game,
but I want to make sure we're clear about this.
When you sign a settlement or you're forced into arbitration,
which is also a secret chamber,
these are the two ways in which our country has deemed that we resolve these
issues.
They're both in silence,
right.
For Women,
what happens is that the perpetrator can go out and say whatever they want
publicly
and the women can't respond.
So is that fair?
I mean that,
that's just biased.
Like you've never even heard of before where the harasser can go out and say,
we know whatever this is,
you know,
none of the allegations are true and,
and the woman can't speak up because if she does,
then she'll lose the settlement that she received.
Yup.
You know?
Or she'll get in troubles some other way legally.
Yeah.
So it's a flawed system and none of it benefits the women at all.
You talk a little bit about that,
we'll circle back to your story,
but you're touching on kind of the public policy aspect of this,
which I find really fascinating in the work that you're doing.
Um,
you know,
to the degree that you know,
there are laws in place,
um,
how can we change the system so that women in the workplace who experienced
harassment have a safe venue to both air these claims and,
um,
get some sort of justice or recourse.
So one of the things I on in the book be fierce is should we really have these
claims and complaints going to human resources?
And when I started talking about this,
I did hear from a lot of great people who work in HR departments.
So I don't,
I don't want to say negative things about all of them cause they said,
look,
we're trying to help.
And so I,
I,
I see that.
However,
I think we need to really be cognizant of the fact that when the harasser could
be the top person at the country who signing the paycheck,
is it really the safest place to go to HR?
Isn't that a conflict of interest?
I say that it is.
So in be fierce,
I advocate a couple of new measures that would maybe help more women to come
forward and keep it a more independent process.
So one of them is to hire an ombudsman who would be an independent safe person,
maybe even anonymously that you would go to and you wouldn't feel like you're
walking down your hallway looking over your back knowing that you just filed a
complaint with somebody who many times the HR people go right to the harasser
and tell them that you filed a claim to make your life even more miserable.
So that's one thing that I proposed.
The second is after the Anita Hill case.
Actually that was the first story I covered as a journalist.
Ironically,
and shortly thereafter I was harassed on the job
buy a camera man in a rural part of Virginia who talked to me when we got back
in the car about how I felt when he touched my breasts by putting the microphone
on me.
And I actually envisioned myself rolling out of the passenger side door B,
this is before cell phones because I was so panicked to get away from him.
So I've had other experiences in my life where I was sexually harassed before
my,
my last place of employment.
But basically in a nutshell,
it drains you of all the self confidence you've built up in your entire life to
be known as a sex object instead of for your brain and for your,
for your talent.
So what I think happened after Anita Hill is that a lot of companies decided to
incorporate sexual harassment training,
you know,
have that be part of their policy.
But what I have found out in my research is that a lot of times it's just a
cover your ass facade for litigious reasons and otherwise for the company to be
able to say,
we provide this.
So one of the things I propose in be fierce is we should really take the focus
of sexual harassment training and move it to more bi standard training.
How do we encourage other employees who know that this is happening,
may witness it or have been told by a colleague that it's happening to also have
the courage to come forward and not feel that they will also be retaliated
against.
We should really refocus the training on how do we celebrate the people who have
the courage to come forward and say it's not a safe working environment.
Instead of just focusing on,
hey,
here's some case studies of sexual sexual harassment and,
and sign on the dotted line so that we know for sure you came to this training
so that we're off the hook,
right?
I mean,
let's really put effort into getting enablers and bystanders to become our
allies
or in,
in,
in some many cases,
uh,
the harassers themselves,
use the HR departments as a foil to say that,
you know,
will no one came forward to make allegations.
How could these claims be true because there's never been a formal process.
But I think that speaks to,
you know what Gretchen is talking about that a lot of people don't feel that HR
is a safe place to,
to make these claims.
So instead they bottle them up and then the only recourse they have is through
litigation.
And,
um,
and that obviously has its own
problems.
Well,
because most of the time you don't take a sexual harassment case to an open
court.
Why?
Because prevalent now in employee contracts are these arbitration clauses.
Yeah.
So talk about,
um,
secret corporate courses as you call them and the way in which,
our employment contracts and perhaps a lot of people here at Google have them as
well.
Um,
when you work for a big company a and you have a claim that you ha you can't sue
them in court,
you have to deal with it in a secret off the record court.
Right?
And so this was never the intention of an arbitration clause.
When Supreme Court ruled on this over 20 years ago.
It really was to not clog the courts,
uh,
but not intended for sexual harassment claims or discrimination claims.
And then that's where they're being utilized though.
So what happens is that you basically sign away your seventh amendment right to
an open Jerry process when you start your job and listen,
nobody starts a job and thinks to themselves,
wow,
I expect to get into a dispute.
I mean,
I know I didn't,
but it's a dark day when you find out in a dispute that you can never tell
anyone what happened ever.
And that's what arbitration is.
So it's secret first and foremost.
So here's a hypothetical.
The woman's being sexually harassed on the job.
She files a complaint.
They immediately put her into arbitration.
The company's going,
we don't have to tell anyone
the woman loses her job
in arbitration.
You don't get the same amount of witnesses or depositions.
The company usually picks the arbitrator and only 20% of the time does the
employee actually win.
And there's no appeal.
Does that sound fair?
So what ends up happening is the woman's out of the job.
She can never tell anyone what happened or that she went through this process.
And the harasser many times gets to stay and nobody knows about it.
And that's been going on for the last couple of decades.
It's why even I didn't realize how pervasive this issue is in the workplace
because we don't hear about these cases.
But the reason we don't hear about these cases is because they're being forced
into secrecy.
And,
um,
when I was reporting on the Fox News sexual harassment scandal last summer,
uh,
one of the women I interviewed,
Rudi Bakhtiar,
who was a,
a correspondent,
uh,
at Fox News,
s years ago,
she broke her NDA.
And,
um,
she was very courageous.
She was the first woman to come forward on the record and give an interview to
me about her experience of harassment after signing an arbitration settlement.
Um,
and she told me,
uh,
the,
the night before interview that she needed to transfer money to her,
uh,
save at,
you know,
basically take all of her life savings and move it to a different bank account
because she was so terrified that Roger Ailes or Fox News would come,
come after her after my,
her interview with me.
Um,
and she thankfully was brave enough to share her story and that really helped
catalyze and,
and uh,
bring the Fox News scandal into the light.
But I think that speaks to the fear that these NDAs have,
um,
that they inspire in,
in victims.
And I guess what I wanted to ask you is,
do you think companies should,
now that we're in the middle of this conversation,
basically say if you've experienced harassment,
um,
we think this is an important public issue to discuss and we should release you
from MDA.
That would be very big of companies to do that.
I think we should all demand that.
Let me just say a little bit about Rudy because she was so brave and doing that
and she was an amazing reporter.
She was from Iran.
She was covering foreign policy,
uh,
for us at Fox and did a great job.
And suddenly she wasn't there anymore.
And I always wondered what happened to Rudy.
You know,
10 years later when she came out to defend me and tell her own story,
I guess I found out what happened to Rudy.
And she's just,
I tell that story because she's the microcosm of the macrocosm of all these
women who've had the American dream taken away from them for no reason except
because of some random jerk.
And,
and that's why we should all be concerned about this as far as Ndas.
There's now a national call for the Weinstein Company and for other companies to
release women from them.
I urge all of you to join that mission.
Um,
because I'm not asking for businesses to not have NDAs for business secrets.
We all understand that.
I feel comfortable signing an NDA that I'm not going to talk about,
you know,
some new technology that you're developing or some big news story that we were
only privy to at our place of employment.
That makes sense,
but not about issues that are violating a human being.
So I think that we should all have a national call for Ndas to not exist
anymore.
Let's see if companies will do it.
Yeah.
But I agree.
I mean I think companies have twisted,
uh,
the,
the use of Ndas to cover up,
you know,
violations of human rights rather than,
protecting corporate secrets or trade practices.
That's,
yeah,
I think that clearly is something that hopefully would galvanize support.
Um,
I want to talk about,
circle back to Kinda your story.
Cause I think,
um,
I've had the privilege of learning more about you and your life and for all of
you out there,
I mean,
Gretchen is a remarkably impressive woman.
Uh,
she was trained as a concert violinist,
uh,
and she was obviously famously Miss America and she went to Stanford University.
I mean,
she is somebody who has set her goals on things and achieve them.
And I want to talk about how you approached your lawsuit and making sure that
your claims would be serious and taken seriously and to advice you have for
other women who are possibly thinking about coming forward,
what steps they can take to make sure that they're protected and find,
sort of be disciplined in how they do it.
Well,
thank you for bringing that up by the way.
We should mention that.
Um,
I was always forbidden from ever knowing Gabe.
I was never supposed to ever meet Gabe.
No.
Gabe was,
um,
cause he was doing a lot of investigative work and I do think it's ironic that
we have become friends.
Yeah.
Um,
whoever thought I'd be sitting on stage with Gabe Sherman.
so that in and of itself,
thank you gain for all the work that you have that you have done in chapter four
of my book.
Be Fierce.
I want it to make sure that I laid out a playbook for women and for men who go
through this.
So it's my 12 point plan.
I don't think it's ever been done before.
And what I'm encouraging women to do is just take it right out of the book and
put it in your back pocket.
Because oftentimes what happens to women in these situations is we think we can
beat this if we just work harder,
we think the harassment will stop.
They'll finally really appreciate us for our brains.
And so we keep persevering and we keep persevering and putting up with it.
And one day we finally just combust and we might go file a complaint.
And you know what the problem with that is?
We don't have a plan.
So my playbook is a plan.
You can't put the genie back in the bottle once you go and make that complaint.
I'll tell you my,
my top three things in the plan of 12 points.
Number one,
you have to call a lawyer first.
There are resources in the back of my book that can show you exactly where you
can call somebody.
They'll take a call for 10 minutes,
tell them what your situation is.
They'll let you know the laws in your state because they're different.
And what your statute of limitations are and also other really important things
like can you have evidence,
can you record?
You know,
in 11 states it's illegal to one party consent record,
so you need to know what the laws are in your state.
Number two,
document,
document.
I talked to a bunch of women in my book who had done just that.
They wrote a journal about what was happening to him.
They saved emails,
they save texts so that they had evidence and then they were fired and they
couldn't go back to their office where they kept all that stuff.
So it home.
Number three,
I know it's so hard,
but tell at least to trusted colleagues because you're going to need the
witnesses.
We still live in a,
he said,
she said culture,
even though we've seen a lot of change over the last 15 months that I'm so
appreciative of your still not going to be believed and you're probably going to
be called a liar and a troublemaker and you just can't take a joke.
So tell to trusted colleagues and I would recommend telling a man,
because I hate to say it,
that's going to probably carry more weight.
If in fact the man says I saw it or I heard it or she told me on December 5th,
2017 that this happened to her,
at least then you have people you know,
defending you instead of feeling like you're 100% alone.
Anyway,
there are nine other tips that are in chapter four,
my playbook,
uh,
be fierce.
I think it's essential that you know,
women and men get this into their hands and that you pass along this same gift
of courage to other people that you know,
that may be facing any injustice in their life.
This is not just about sexual harassment.
This is about being fierce and standing up and speaking up about any way in
which you don't feel you're being treated fairly.
Whether that's pay inequity or bullying in school for our kids or not getting a
seat in the boardroom or not getting the promotion you deserve.
This is about a movement of standing up and speaking up for you to be the best
person you can be.
We've seen obviously the,
the swiftness of the downfall up say a Harvey Weinstein.
Do you think now we're at a place where companies do have a zero tolerance
policy when a powerful executive has been exposed for this behavior or do you
think unfortunately this may be kind of a a fleeting moment and will revert to
the kind of the status quo.
I am surprised based on how our new cycles change so quickly now and our
attention spans are so limited that we are still talking about this three weeks
after the Weinstein story broke.
But I am so heartened that we are because it means that all of the work that
I've been doing and others have been doing for the last 15 months,
it's paying off.
You know when you think about cultural shifts with race relations or you know,
gay and lesbian and transgender issues,
they don't have an overnight.
So the idea that we have come this far in 15 months gave,
I mean I really feel,
I tend to be an optimistic person,
but I really think that this is amazing and I don't think we're going to turn
back.
I mean you look at what happened.
Now you have the Amazon studios executives,
you have the other,
you know,
Hollywood director with all those complaints.
That was,
I was just blown away when I saw that La Times headline where the director James
Toe back,
um,
had been accused originally,
uh,
in an article by 30 women.
And then several days later the newspaper had heard from,
uh,
you know,
more than a hundred more.
And I think the total was over 202 things as I felt as a reporter that it was
shocking that this was out there and he wasn't in jail.
I mean the guy seems like a straight up sexual predator.
And then secondly that now women have the courage to just come forward and call
it out.
I think men will not be able to sort of do that.
A pervasive,
uh,
behavior without the fear of exposure.
Now.
Well in ones who have already done it,
they're in the fetal position.
Right?
Yeah.
You know,
they're,
they're just waiting for the women to be emboldened at their place of
employment.
So I do,
I do see this as a cascading effect.
What my hope is is that media will continue to cover this and cover the stories
of the women that are not famous because that's the majority of the women,
you know,
a young woman in Boise,
Idaho.
You know,
talk a little bit about,
um,
some of the women you've heard from,
uh,
who again are everyday Americans working either in the service industry and the
restaurant industry,
um,
and what their experiences have been like in,
and how they've tried to seek justice.
Yeah.
So basically all of their stories where nobody would ever listen to him.
I never had a voice.
Uh,
you know,
I was maligned.
I mean,
it's the same sort of story and I would just wait for it as I would respond to
all of these women and then eventually get on the phone with them for the book
without failure.
All of them would say,
my industry is an old boys' club.
It didn't matter what it was,
even female oriented business areas like retail or the cosmetic industry.
And
I think the one thing that they felt so fearful of was can I really come forward
because I need my paycheck?
And one of the questions that really not at me,
Gabe and gave me a lot of sleepless nights was how do I help the single mom who
can't afford to do this?
Right?
It doesn't have the resources that I had,
doesn't have the national platform that I had.
And so through my fund that I've set up gift of courage,
um,
I've now started the Gretchen Carlson leadership initiative,
which will kick off next month,
November in Dallas Fort Worth.
It's a nine city tour,
three days of workshops in each city for underserved women.
They can come for free and learn about sexual harassment,
domestic violence,
give legal advice and learn how to have a voice civically and politically in
life.
Because what tends to happen when you are going through something like this in
your life,
you feel alone and you feel like you don't have a voice,
not just on that issue.
You feel like you don't have a voice on anything.
And I want to be able to provide these women the opportunity to become involved
in their communities and get out of the shadows of a victim.
So I'm incredibly proud to be financing that leadership initiative as the start
to helping more women to have a voice.
And you know,
obviously we can't have this conversation in a vacuum.
And I think we have to look at,
um,
the national,
uh,
political landscape that we're all living in.
And we have a president of the United States,
um,
who himself has been accused by multiple women,
uh,
very similar types of,
of unwanted advances and himself was caught on tape.
They famous access Hollywood tape,
you know,
boasting about what he does,
uh,
with women.
Are you surprised or I guess what I'm trying to get at is,
do you think,
you know,
the election in November,
was the sort of the last gasp of that old culture where that behavior was,
was tolerated?
Or do you think somehow politics is different than corporate America where
people are willing to look the other way because they care about x,
y,
or z issue and they just want to vote for their party?
Uh,
well,
I think that until recently it was similar in the sense that you had a lot of
people covering up and also that,
uh,
people put political policies ahead of human decency.
Hmm.
I mean,
for me,
listening to that tape,
sorry,
it was really personal.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
I know Donald Trump,
I'd known him for 27 years and,
and you know,
a week after my story broke,
he came out against me and said that from everything he had read
that he didn't believe me.
So it was personal for me when I heard the access Hollywood tape and I feature
actually Natasha Stone off the people magazine writer who accused him of
unwanted advances in my book be fierce.
I felt it was important to give her a voice.
Okay.
You know that access Hollywood tape.
I think if you're a parent,
I hope you used it as a teachable moment for your kids.
I know I did for mine.
And again,
forget political policy.
It's my opinion that the way in which we treat human beings supersedes that.
And that's all I cared about with that tape.
I wanted my kids to know this is not how you treat people.
Now here's the difference.
When powerful people in private companies are exposed,
they can be fired.
But we can't fire politicians who've been elected.
That's just up for the next vote.
So I guess in a way you can,
but um,
it's not something that would happen as swiftly.
So,
you know,
I guess we'll just have to wait and see how this all flushes out and how,
what reaction that will have them on.
See American people.
Everyone still has a boat.
Yeah.
Um,
so I would love to open it up to the audience.
If anyone has questions.
Um,
you can please step two.
I think there's two microphones,
um,
and just,
say your name and uh,
you're free to ask questions if you have them.
There's our first brave soul.
Gretchen,
thank you so much for being here today.
Your words are incredibly inspiring and I'm so appreciative you've taken the
stand to represent women who really do need this voice.
Thank you.
One question I had for you in chapter four was the idea of training incivility.
Can you give us some examples of companies that have done this and have been
successful with that effort?
Um,
so there is an international cosmetic company which has really gone way beyond
and being progressive about this bystander training.
Uh,
and,
and that's really what I mean about civility.
It's about let's teach employees what to do instead of what not to do.
Right.
That is the essence of it.
And the interesting thing that I learned from,
from this company was that there's 70% female employed around the world.
And even though they have these incredibly progressive ways to report it,
and once a week this committee gets together and listens to all the complaints
and they handle them immediately,
but here's what they told me.
They don't really have a lot of sexual harassment complaints and I was like,
wow,
how simple is that?
I said,
why?
They said,
well,
we have 70% of our company is women.
So that led me to really start thinking about,
wow,
wouldn't it be fabulous if we just started employing more women as we should be
into these roles and put them into positions of power so that this type of
activity doesn't happen.
You see,
this is how it prospers,
is that we don't have enough women in those positions being able to say,
stop,
but it's why I'm calling on men,
especially to help us with that because as long as men dominate running the
fortune 500 companies right now,
what is it,
94% we need them and we want them,
and by the way in be fierce.
I have an entire chapter on men because I found so many great men already out
there doing fantastic work.
It's my longest chapter.
So most men want to help us.
Most men want a safe work environment for women.
We just have to convince them to take that little extra step of courage and stop
being the bystander and stop being the enabler and help us in and being an ally.
Thank you.
Yes.
My name is Kelsey.
I'm,
I just wanted to thank you so much for being here and sharing your story and
sharing us,
telling us how to be fierce,
I guess.
Um,
and you spoke a lot about harassment in the workplace.
Obviously that's what your book is about and that's what your story is.
Um,
and speaking with the women about,
um,
the industry's being a boys club and my experience,
I feel like our society is a boy's club.
And I was wondering if you have any advice or,
um,
for women that are harassed in public on the street?
I know every day I face that and it's really hard to be cat called and harassed.
I'm just going home or coming to work or anywhere that I go and then I feel like
I'm losing my power.
And I know that you,
your book is all about taking your power back.
Um,
so I feel safe at work obviously.
Thanks Google.
But what advice do you have for women to take their power back in public or in
the street?
Right.
And that happens just because they feel like they can write.
It's like,
to me it's the insecurity of that person calling out and trying to take away
your confidence.
So I mean it's one of the things that I say in the playbook that you can also do
in the workplace is to take offense.
I mean,
not that I'm not a funny person.
Listen,
I like to have more fun than anyone that I,
that I really know.
It's not that I can't take a joke,
it's that you need to take back your self esteem and your pride and just say,
oh,
thank you so much.
I don't really appreciate that though.
I mean,
you can say it,
you know,
in a nonthreatening way.
But the other really central thing that I think changes society is the way in
which we choose to raise our children.
And at the end of the book,
I have a whole chapter on parenting.
And really what I think is crucial is how we raise our sons.
I think it's imperative that we teach gender equality within the family unit,
whether that's a husband and wife together or partners or single parents or
whatever the case is.
They're watching us and they're hearing us.
And if you're showing respect for gender at home,
that's what they're going to carry through when they get to the workplace.
So I think it's really central.
I think we should be doing sexual harassment training and classes for middle
school kids and moving on up into high school.
I'm doing a college campus tour with my book be fierce because I think it's,
especially on college campuses,
one in five women are going to face sexual assault and what is the Greek system
do?
What kind of messages?
Not to narc on them completely,
but what does that teach our young men about how to be,
and then they go right from there to the workforce,
you know?
So I really think that getting to our young people is essential and crucial to
moving the needle forward for our ultimate respect for women once we get into
the workplace and on the streets.
Thank you.
Thank you Kelsey.
Thanks.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming today and for and for so bravely sharing your story
because this is a system that perpetuates in secrecy and shame.
Um,
and I guess I don't know how much you can answer this question and I don't mean
it to sound politically pointed,
but having spent time at a,
at a media environment,
which arguably has,
um,
actively perpetuated objectification of women and a very rape,
supportive culture with the active endorsement and promotion of our now
president who's advocated sexual violence against women,
um,
how do you reflect on your time and participation in that system and your
experience of them being so publicly rejected from it?
But what I can say is that to a certain extent,
all people can fall into cultish behavior.
I've always been a supporter of women,
always call my mom up.
She used to get so bugged by me calling her early in my career and throughout
and saying,
you know,
women aren't paid fairly,
et cetera.
And she'd be like,
why do you always have to talk about women's rights stuff?
And I'm like,
because I'm living it.
And then when she started running the company late later in her life in her
sixties and still today at 76 she calls me every day and says,
now I know what you're talking about.
Um,
that's the extent of what I can say about my last 11 years.
But please know that I have always been an advocate for women.
Well,
you mentioned just a on,
on that point on Twitter,
I think recently I saw you said you don't know what my parameters were.
So I guess that was alluding to how even within the system at Fox you were
trying to carve out your own space.
Yes,
you can say that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you so much for being here.
Your words are very inspiring and I think we're in a moment right now where more
women are feeling the courage to come forward.
I was struck by your comment around,
um,
you know,
finally the day when you're recognized for your brain's not your beauty.
Right?
And I am sure many women in the room and men can relate to that of being
complimented on your looks instead of your talents.
Um,
I had a colleague toast a big project and in front of 40 people comment on how
good I looked as well as being talented on the project.
And at that moment I realized,
wow,
no one would ever say that to a male colleague.
You wouldn't say he's so great at his job and he looks so great,
you would never hear that.
So how do you think we can more proactively model emphasizing talents overlooks
in the worth of women in the workplace?
I mean,
again,
it starts young gear story reminds me of Senator Kirsten Gillibrand from,
from this state actually.
I interviewed her for the book and she was telling me a story about how when she
was at her law firm before she ran for office,
that similarly she had,
you know,
won this huge case and at the toast they talked about her great new haircut.
Yeah.
She was like,
wait a minute,
I just had this huge win,
you know,
and it was so demoralizing and your,
your self worth just drains,
you know,
in quick fashion.
I don't know,
there,
there's something in our society that doesn't allow us yet to honor a woman who
happens to be attractive,
smart and talented.
There must be something wrong with her,
you know?
So we,
we focus then on the looks first.
Now I'm going to be the first to tell you that I think media plays into that.
I don't really watch TV that much.
I just really have been a news junkie and over the last couple of months when I
turn on Primetime TV,
I'm like horrified that my kids might be watching this stuff and the
sexualization of women.
So I think that's where it comes from.
And his parents.
I don't know how we completely control,
I mean,
you can control it in your house as much as you possibly can,
but they go to school and they do live in the outside world.
And Are we really going to be able to change the imagery that we're putting out
to our kids,
not to mention porn.
So to me,
the way to really try to combat that is to raise our sons differently.
I come back to that point.
Well,
I,
you know,
I just want to jump in on that because I noticed in a lot of the news accounts
of the Weinstein and these other scandals,
you know,
people would come forward and say,
oh,
well for my daughter I'm going to do this.
And as a father of a,
a new daughter,
I think that in it,
I know the intention is there.
But to me,
I also find that language diminishing of women because it shouldn't just be for
daughters.
It should,
I mean,
they're equal to men.
It should be a human issue.
Whether you have a son or a daughter,
you should,
I want to raise my,
uh,
my children to be respectful and I'm not speaking out or I don't report on this
issue because I have a daughter.
Right?
I mean,
I will give credit to,
uh,
the men who stopped me on the streets of New York and shake my hand and do say
thank you for my daughters.
I think it,
it hits home for fathers more when they hear these stories and they do have
daughters at home and if,
and if that ignites them to be part of this be fierce movement.
Fantastic.
But you're exactly right.
I,
I've often said that I worked more for my son than I did for my daughter.
And what I meant by that was that I wanted him to see what I did every day and
respect his eventual female colleagues in the workplace in the same way in which
he looked at his mom.
So I do agree that,
that the parody is,
is essential.
And actually more of the focus should be on the sons and the daughters.
So actually I as a mother to a daughter and my question was about,
um,
just the conversation with,
with a daughter,
she's eight years old.
And I think one of the most difficult times for me as a parent was election
night.
Just knowing that in the morning I would have to,
you know,
break this news that this like horrible,
bully that she'd come to kind of understand a was now like elected popularly or
not popularly whatever
is the leader I left cause right.
Constitutionally he was elected.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
so I had to explain all this to her.
I never felt so much like fear and like just devastation and trying to explain a
sub,
you know,
uh,
happening to her and I was just trying really hard to like not to break down in
front of her and to tell her like,
this is going to be okay.
Um,
but anyway,
so just listening to this and having had my own experiences and watching all of
this,
you know,
um,
come forward,
I wonder about how to talk to her about what may end up unfortunately being her
experiences in the future.
And I just wanted to get your thoughts and you know,
what would you say to a daughter,
I don't know actually know if you have a daughter or not,
but like what can we do?
What can we do protect our girls
and help them to protect themselves.
So I have a 14 year old daughter who actually I just took with me on my la part
of my book tour because I thought it was really important for her to see me.
Well,
she also thought La was cool but uh,
to,
to even take her out of school,
to show her what mom was doing,
you know,
um,
and,
and I think it's imperative that our kids see us standing up and speaking up and
being courageous because I can tell you what it transferred to my kids almost
immediately.
My greatest concern was how will my kids fare through this?
And I've seen the bravery in my kids transplanted.
It's contagious.
So my daughter finally had the courage to speak up at school about some kids who
were bugging her and came home and said,
mom,
I did it cause I saw you do it.
I mean that is how it starts.
Right.
And as far as you know,
being however you felt about the election,
okay,
I really want to turn it around and say that it's a positive.
This is our chance to be able to have a voice on these issues and speak about
them more openly.
I mean I have to look at it optimistically and currently where we are right now,
I do think it's optimistic that we're talking about these issues so much.
And third I would just say,
okay,
that is eight years old,
may be a little young.
But I played the access Hollywood tape for my kids.
Okay.
On purpose because I wanted them to hear how you don't treat people.
And I think that's the way in which we move forward on this issue is to be open
and honest about it.
Right.
Hi Steph off.
Thank you for being here.
Um,
so my question for you is,
um,
I feel a greater sense of urgency then just the role modeling for our children.
I couldn't agree with you more.
I have a four year old daughter and eight year old son and I believe so strongly
in the best thing I can do is role model the behavior I want to see in them.
Um,
but to the point of urgency because it's gonna be a long time until they're in
middle school and high school and in the workforce.
You talked about parameters and I'm sure you can't share specifically.
Maybe you can talk about it hypothetically bring abstract.
What guidance would you have with feel very privileged working at Google?
I'm not saying we're perfect,
but I feel very privileged.
So I'm curious to hear from you perspective on parameters or grassroots things
that we could do.
I'm just,
I'm horrified by what you're describing,
you know,
in contracts that people sign and an awareness that you would,
you hope to bring to this movement.
What I would call a movement.
What can we do from a grassroots standpoint to help catalyze change
saints,
especially at progressive companies like Google.
I think it,
it's really important to put together group discussions of employees and talk
about whether or not you have arbitration clauses and whether or not you can
work with HR to possibly,
you know,
let's talk about amending these or at least taking the secrecy out of
arbitration or at least giving,
uh,
your employees the choice of whether or not they want it to be secret or not,
right.
Start Group discussions about that in progressive companies that are willing to
really listen to their employees.
I think that that is,
is one way to start and to also look at your sexual harassment training
policies.
You know,
I know that what happened to me over time was that they eventually just came
through compliance on your computer,
right?
And you just had to,
instead of actually going to the training,
we just had to like check off boxes and everyone pretty much to just did it as
fast as I could,
but really lobby within your company for changing the way in which you are
training people specifically to what we were talking before about bystander
training.
Don't just teach us about what sexual harassment is and give us case studies and
say,
here's what bad people do.
Teach us about how do we empower people to come forward and help.
That's really the essential training.
So those two things I would encourage,
encourage you to have just like you might have a book club,
but to have to come together.
I've already heard from young people all across the country since I've been on
tour,
that they're starting these kinds of movements within their own companies and
also I would have thirdly,
the discussion about the confidentiality clauses.
Yes,
let's protect business secrets,
especially at a place like Google.
I know you're on the cutting edge and nobody wants to to violate that,
but do we really have to be secret about everything?
Let's give a voice back to our employees because that is so incredibly
empowering and that only makes the employee want to work here more and stay here
for a long time if they know that they're in a safe environment.
Thank you.
Um,
well,
I think this is all the time we have today.
Thank you so much for,
um,
participating in this very important discussion.
And let's all give a round of applause for Gretchen.